>> YOU WILL REACH YOUR
DESTINATION IN SIX HOURS.
>> THIS IS THE WORST, MILES OF
GRAY HIGHWAY WITH THIS MONOTON
LADY GIVING DIRECTIONS.
>> HOW ABOUT WE SWITCH MODES ON
THE GPS.
>> SWITCH MODES/.
>> YEAH, LOOK, THERE'S AMERICAN
MALE, AMERICAN FEMALE, AND THIS
ONE -- DRAG ENTERTAINER.
>> WELL, THAT SOUNDS UNUSUAL AND
FUN.
>> YES, QUEEN, I'M GAGGING ON
THIS SCENIC BYWAY I'M GIVING
YOU.
>> INTRODUCING CP-YA, WITH THE
POPULARITY OF RUPAUL'S DRAG
RACE, CHARMIN HAS EXTENDED OUR
VOICE OPTIONS TO INCLUDE DRAG
ENTERTAINER.
LET'S GP-YA TURN YOUR
UNSTIMULATING TRIP INTO A
SICKENING ONE.
>> LOOK, HONEY, THE ICONS FOR
THE CAR IS A GLAMOUR LINK
FINGERNAIL.
>> ENTERING SCHOOL ZONE!
>> BITCH, SLOW YOUR ASS DOWN SO
YOU DON'T SQUASH A CHILD FLAT
LIKE A SQUIRREL.
>> EVEN THE WARNINGS ARE
ENJOYABLE.
>> I CAN'T SEE THE MAP, BUT I
DON'T CARE.
>> GP-YA KEEPS UPDATED ON
TRAFFIC ALERTS AND DISASTER
AREAS.
>> DISASTER AREA UP AHEAD!
>> IT'S A DAMN VAN.
>> OH, HONEY, I THINK YOU MISSED
THE EXIT.
>> TURN AROUND.
TURN AROUND!
>> YOU GO, GIRL.
WHAT DID I SAY?
>> YOU ARRIVED!
♪ JUST MAKE IT FUN AND FREE
YOU'RE GONNA LIVE FOREVER
FOLLOW ME TO THE ENDS OF THE
EARTH
WE'RE GOING IT TOGETHER
YES, YES ♪♪♪
>> GP-YASSS, SOLD IN ANY TOWN
WHERE THERE'S STILL A CIRCUIT
CITY.